c'est un soulagement non ce magasin de
vêtements après un samedi 17 novembre
catastrophique lors du premier week-end
de mobilisation des gilet jaune c'est le
retour à la normale ils ont compris que
bloquer bloquer toutes les formes de
commerce où toutes les actes et les
secteurs économiques commerces c'est pas
forcément la solution
parce que après les conséquences ou
peut-être grave parce que nous c'est
vrai que l'approché des fêtes de fin
d'année on prend des cdd moins nombreux
le week-end dernier les barrages
filtrants des gilet jaune n'ont pas
entravé la circulation des consommateurs
la gérante de cette boutique peut
souffler mais si la majorité de ses
clients sont revenus ces derniers jours
elle ne cache pas son inquiétude
c'est très important que ça se débloque
et si je fais me si je rate mon mois de
décembre ça va être très dure derrière
la préfecture met en place une ligne
téléphonique dédiée aux acteurs
économiques dont l'activité est
perturbée par les troubles liés au
rassemblement la préfecture de saône et
loire a mis en place ce numéro d'urgence
pour rassurer les commerçants afin de
les conseiller les orienter vers les
services publics compétents jusqu'ici
nié que quelques appels dans le
département mais le service restera en
place jusqu'à la fin du mouvement des
gilet jaune